If you thought I would benefit from Ivermectin against breast cancer when you
do the cheek swab or even the genetic analysis could, you have suggested I
asked my doctor about it. I can't test for that because it is a prescription
medication whereas versus venvenous oils and over-the-counter medication so I can't
test for that so I can't do that. But I've said over and over. I think there's
any downside of taking Ivermectin. No, I really don't see a big downside in
taking Ivermectin. You can argue well could it throw off your gut flora, your
microbiota possibly? That would be the only downside. It would not throw off
your gut flora like taking it in a biotic one. So I don't see any downside. If
you're doing well on your current protocol, I guess I wouldn't add it but if I
was in a situation where I feel like I'm kind of slipping or going a little bit
downhill, I would consider adding it especially if you if you are you feel
really led in that way. So follow, finish up the question. My GP is cooperative
and will help. I suppose that means in prescribing it. I'm already on a parasite
cleanse protocol. So the benefit of Ivermectin and cancer really isn't the
parasitic, anti-parasitic effect of the Ivermectin. It's basically an off-label
effect meeting. It's not that it's killing parasites and therefore benefiting
somebody with cancer because they have parasites. It's working on a different
metabolic pathway. Same thing with femenazole. Does femenazole work for some
people with cancer because their cancer is caused by parasitic worms because
femenazole is a medication for parasitic worms. So is that the reason why it helps
with some people with cancer? Because their cancer is caused from parasitic worms. That
at all, not at all. It's it's it's working on a different metabolic pathway that's
slowly the growth of cancer has nothing to do with. It's it's benefit to help kill
worms. So same thing with Ivermectin. It's working on a completely different path.